foreign
okay good morning everybody I think we
ought to get hopping here on our
business today we have in front of us uh
several bills uh three of them uh 1366
1399 and 1679 all relative to
Cooperative schools and we've combined
them into one uh uh interim study
committee to look at and we did discuss
those uh to a great degree at the last
meeting we had the second bill is uh
1680.
um which is a bill uh dealing with the
foundational Foundation opportunity Pro
budget for uh adequacy and we will we
will do that one at 10 30 following this
this if we can conclude this meeting by
9 30. It Is
by 10 30 excuse me and and then we'll
just roll right into a scene this is a
interim study committee
um we will obviously accept you know
presentations or testimony during this
uh not testimony but technical support
and and then uh roll in uh to 10 30. I'd
like to get the Cooperative uh School
Board reapportionment bills and and
corporate School District withdrawal
information and and and and disillusion
and repeal those are what the three
things are all about let's get those try
to uh get those things moving forward
somehow in terms of of a recommendation
I do have a uh
a suggestion that came forth from
initially this suggestion came forth
uh when we are just discussing it prior
to making the interim study motion it
came for us from uh the New Hampshire
school boards Association to establish a
commission study to more thoroughly
investigate and look at Cooperative
school districts since then I've
received uh last night
from the Department a they've looked at
that recommendation that came in from
the school boards Association and
identified perhaps those people that
should be on a commission study and and
looked at the duties and
responsibilities of the commission and
added to it based upon our discussion at
the previous meeting
trying to help us out and and derive
some kind of a direction here so I'm
going to pass that out to you right now
so you'll see what came in from doe last
night I got this from this like must
have been about 5 30 in the afternoon I
opened it up at midnight last night and
and saw it and whoa whoa and so I'm
gonna pass it around this way and that
there's ample copies here for the public
a few more you need a few more that way
you'll take those
and I'll save a couple here for those
who might come in
you got enough right there
going all the way around take one okay
sure
just a few remarks about The Cooperative
school districts
in our discussion last week we had folks
presenting to us or testifying or
offering us support
and it appeared to me that we have the
majority of Cooperative school districts
according to what we heard maybe
two-thirds are okay with it the way it
is one-third of the ones that have these
issues or or among one District within
may have those issues uh as far as how
do I get out of this how do we resolve
how to get out of it Etc
and and so um
with that we came up with the
um
idea that this we don't have all the
answers for this then last night being a
old school principal Minister it came
out of Maine we had the same issues over
there with sad school administrative
districts School unions which readfield
is in a school Union which is different
than the sad and then you have the
singular districts like the city of
Portland and some smaller there's a lot
of different makeups over there too and
when they went and tried to consolidate
and do that that you know didn't
consolidate a lot of districts one that
I know of was Rumford Mexico but they
are right beside each other and the
other side of the androscogen river and
they did tie together seeing they were
going to do that probably anyways
when we look at what happened in Vermont
where if they didn't have a k through 12
District they were all the little k6s
and k3s and k-8s we're told you will try
to tie in with a full K through 12. well
that that has been done but they're
they're but done through tuitioning
programs like where my grandkids are
going to school and Barnett now the
tuition to either Lyndon or Saint Jay
Academy so they have a tuition from
Vermont's had a tuition program way
before we had a tuition program
so in looking at where we go if we if we
say we're going to
destroy the Cooperative school districts
and start over from scratch we are
headed down the road to a tremendous
problem and an Untold consequences and I
just think that that's that's going to
be a very difficult process to maneuver
through although some may think that's
the way to go with through due to
frustration if we haven't been able to
resolve this in the last umpteen years
um
now so let's take a look at what we've
got here in front of us in terms of the
recommendation or the thoughts which we
had the preceding meeting we were
looking at a thorough well done
commission study not that the one done
in 2017 wasn't that
but we have been told that it didn't go
far enough in a lot of respects and
there are still still some districts
that didn't even have articles of
agreement two of them
one thing we got to note in a commission
study and I was reminded of this by uh
our Jennifer fore HB 1629 was a bill
that passed the legislature this last
session
it stipulates that any future
uh
commissions committee commissions or
other types of working groups which
involve both non-elected officials and
elected officials must have a majority
of elected officials on that Commission
and the commission can be no larger than
15 members
so when you look at the way that this
commission was recommended years ago
that bear Christina kindly offered to US
during the testimony and all that the
makeup of non-uh elected officials Way
Beyond the you know the the limit which
would be if you had 15 only seven people
could come from uh not only eight would
have to come from elected officials we
know I know from my experience it's
tough to get on any kind of study
eight elected legislators there's a lot
of reasons why they can't attend or it's
just very difficult many of you are
sitting on various groups right now and
you see that happening like the CTE
Council that would that's another one
which would be revamped with this
particular policy that went through and
now it's state law
so when we're looking at that we can
have technical support
on any of these commissions
so you would list the
active members the voting members and
there'd have to be a majority of elected
officials on that Senate in the house
we we can develop a commission that has
technical support you can even list
those technical support people in a
commission report as part of the
commission but the non-voting members
everybody get where I'm coming from on
this
that was a bill that came out uh of uh
president
legislative Administration and all that
uh and it was a bipartisan bill
and I didn't catch it
and that's the way that we lost
legislative oversight committee one year
we didn't catch it and we had to go and
reinstate it this last year we did that
so
in looking at the makeup of the
commission study here if that's the
route we're going and this is what I'd
like to do is look at this first first
of all I'd like to find out from the
committee are we all on the same page as
far as if we're going to make a
recommendation up or down
that on these bills now we know that
anybody can this elected can introduce
any one of these bills again that we
can't stop that from happening
but from the education committee's
perspective
um do we feel comfortable in in going
forward with any one of those bills or
are we on the same page as far as we
need to have a better understanding of
all the results and the actions might
occur as a result of our taking action
too so Rick a question for you on that
do you have um
if if there were to be a
uh well we have to do interim study
reports for each of the
that's correct each of the bills like
you said what um what do you
um what are you thinking the reports
would look like if um if the committee
was to move forward with a
recommendation for a uh commission to
study this if you're going to have a
commission study then you would look on
this and see what all the duties and
responsibilities that committee would be
no but I'm talking about it on the on
the on the two sentence report yeah on
the two sentence report I would I would
suggest that we we say that for this
particular bill which is maybe dealing
with disillusion which is a component of
the larger study we want to look at I
would I would indicate that we cannot
support this bill moving forward as we
recommend that uh a a commission study
be done to look at these particular
issues and and you know you don't have
to go into depth as this would but
because a dissolution uh
bonding all the stuff associated with
debt of buildings articles agreement you
don't have to list all that but you can
list the broad topics in that last
sentence so you I think we can do it in
just a two two sentence type report
but suggest that and and then have
available as a recommendation we can
have this as a sort of like an addendum
to our recommendation as a committee
this is what we would recommend it's
available to anybody who wants to move
forward so maybe maybe something a
commission to review and propose changes
to RSA 195.
yeah I mean just keep it at a yeah 30
000 foot level yeah that's fine with me
I I the wording that uh you know the
study report does what I would like to
also say though that we did look at this
yeah and that we do have a
recommendation regarding the commission
membership and duties responsibilities
associated with that commission or
something such as that so that this is
available if that's what we want to do
we can discuss that when we're doing
that on the 24th because that's where we
make the final decision right right
but the issue right now are we in favor
of all of us the idea that we would do
the commission angle rather than
um
well the all of them would be down then
and then we would have this same kind of
uh recommendation for all three of them
right
yes represent Tanner
um I agree that we need a commission
um I it seems like all we're focusing on
is dissolution and you said you know
there are that's just one topic let's
look at them that you know as I said
before the co-ops were developed by
incentives from the Department of
Education and I for one feel that uh
there should be at least some discussion
about how we can support co-ops in order
to keep them going because uh with the
economy of scale once these people break
up you know just like lemster and Goshen
I mean it's minus it it just costs them
a lot of money uh just to run the
schools because it's so small so I think
that you know there needs to be two
sides to this coin not only dissolution
but also what can be done to help the
ones that that want to maintain or even
the ones that want to dissolve and
realize that they can't what can the
state do to offer them some incentives
to keep up their their Cooperative
districts so if you look at this this
report that I got from Dio this is doe
and and the school boards Association
the doe and um Diana's here today uh
this came in from Liz
is this something that um
there's been some discussion over at doe
in regard to what we should do as a
subcommittee here on this anybody from
do you want to speak to it yes good
morning
um so I received that above my request
the button yeah yeah
now it's on
um
I had requested that from Barrett
Christina understanding that he had
submitted it to you I guess a year ago
and we reviewed it commissioner and I
reviewed it
um we made some revisions to it if you
can I can provide you a black line
between what Barrett had submitted a
year ago and how we revised it
um I think we revised the composition
but also parsed out some of the items
that we would think would be subject to
review and discussion by that Commission
thank you Liz
um and that's in Roman 2 on this report
which we have here for a and I did take
the
the opportunity last night to add in one
more to that okay but um
I'd like to if we could walk through
these item item item because we have a
little time here and see if this answers
some of the things represent Tanner that
you were just raising
um uh it shouldn't be just how to get
out you know it's it's obviously when
we're talking many other aspects of
Education like in building a we look at
consolidation as a a key component of
receiving and rating applications in
other words you know you're not
splintering and going to cost more
dollars you're trying to do a savings of
dollars in terms of administration of
functioning as a school with
consolidation
so
um that's what I'd like to do is take
right 2A right now Roman 2A look at that
and then is that something that we would
recommend as a Duty or responsibility of
the commission
yes representing cardelli yes um I I
think that's a key area to look at
um I think that a lot of the frustration
over the years has been in that area
um many if not most of the bills we've
received over the time that I've been
here which is a considerable number have
been related to the withdrawal process
and it's uh almost impossible for a
smaller District
to withdraw from a Cooperative
given the majority vote of the entire
Cooperative so that's a key area I think
thank you Mr chair I would just offer
that we put something in there about
sustainability and support for co-ops
that that it be explored
I I'm I'm hearing what you're saying but
let's let's say what we think we should
go in here as an addition after we go
through all these elements
sustainability of a co-op and the
importance of a co-op may already be in
here it's one of those statements I
haven't read through it that thoroughly
so
um but keep that you know write that
down right now sustainability of co-ops
in the interest of of Education
um
so yeah one third of the districts
that's usually what part of the issue is
you know how do I get out
um
children in our district aren't getting
what they deserve it's costing us more
money Etc or whatever the issue is it's
usually about how do I withdraw from the
co-op so obviously that should be a
process that's looked at uh B the powers
and review authority of the State Board
of Education in the withdrawal process
b r c the educational impact of
withdrawal from a Cooperative School
District on the educational
opportunities for the students impacted
by withdrawal or dissolution of
Cooperative school districts yes
I can see this happening especially the
high school level where
Town moves but there and has a different
high school going to but the students
are in the bigger high school with the
co-op with subjects that aren't being
supplied and the new thing they're going
so one of the agreements could be that
they stay until they graduate I mean
we've done that in an area agreement
type thing so that's one of the things
on the educational impact where they're
going in other subjects going to follow
them
yeah that's all related yeah
any discussion on C further going down
to D educational options for students
who are impacted by the withdrawal of
dissolution of Co-op school districts
that's sort of like you were what you
were looking at oh yeah D the options
you know do it oh yeah
do I stay or do I go somewhere else and
then in are there any places else to go
to
um that has to be approved by a
receiving School
um
um he appraisal valuation of real estate
and Facilities of existing Cooperative
District
that's a huge issue right there
you know how do we divvy up debt how do
we divvy up what you have put into the
buildings the structures
are you willing to leave without having
to you know demand a certain amount of
money come back to you as a leaving
District
uh does for financial issues that we
heard from
uh uh the um the accounts for State
Attorneys uh he the attorney was from
Drummond wasn't he we heard last week uh
Shaughnessy
Jim yeah yeah
um
F uh no let's see what let's see uh
e appraisal evaluation okay
um of a state
and Facilities of the existing
Cooperative District
um
F appraisal evaluation of other non-real
estate facilities assets of the existing
Cooperative District a lot of financial
issues the legal impact and withdrawal
of pre-existing District or dissolution
of the district on any existing
collective bargaining agreement
um upon dissolution of a co-op or
withdrawal from Cooperative District how
assets including but not limited to
facilities contractual agreements and
other tangible property are divided
between the copper District any
withdrawing district and or the
pre-existing districts
I representation on a Cooperative School
District board and how board members are
elected board representation allocated
between pre-existing districts Etc
that was an issue that I think came from
uh representative uh
Melissa Litchfield here who had a
district that wanted representation
J surveys and public opinions of parents
students and community members of
pre-existing school districts and a
consideration of the issues and
considerations that drive those opinions
including but not limited to educational
opportunities availability of
co-curricular and extracurricular
activities in Cooperative districts tax
rates disparity of costs per pupil and
equalize valuation of real estate among
other issues that's a lot in that one
right there deals with uh so much
needs to be looked at all of it needs to
um
K on the other page identify key
required elements in Cooperative School
articles of agreement and require all
Cooperative school districts to have
approved articles of agreement I stocked
that one in that was one that didn't
come from Liz but um we we know there's
several districts that don't have
articles of agreement so all those
policy decisions are based upon what
clearly state law but where are all the
the districts within the co-op do they
all agree with what's going on it's
I don't know how those other co-ops
don't have agreements how they function
how they review those
will review what they're doing
um and the L any necessary revisions to
RSA 195 or any other statute that may
uniquely impact a proper School District
so that's kind of wide open Deal
any other issue which the commission
deems relevant to the objective of this
study
now
representative Tanner
so in in the one that you added about
the articles of agreement I don't know
if it's maybe it's a silly thing but I
would put down written because I think
if they don't have articles of agreement
there's been like a
an agreement but it's not been written
down
um and so maybe if you put written in
there then well I I think that's very
valuable and capped so a lot of these
articles we can't find you know we've
gone to doe and asked they can't find
them um
I don't know how those districts are
functioning
a handshake
uh and and I I thought the ones that
don't have written articles agreement
are they functioning are they getting
are they the ones that wanted
I honestly can't tell you maybe there's
somebody here that can inform us there
were two districts
that don't have articles agree what's
I can't read from our discussion
previously it came up in the discussion
yeah in fact I think Barrett was the one
who brought it up
yes yeah and how they're functioning now
on a handshake
Rick I would assume there is some issues
of past practice
that would cover the questions that
representative Cornell is talking about
that has been there for years and the
past practice is a common
common law issue where there's not a
so
um
the last M any other issue which the
commission deems relevant to the object
objective of the study is kind of a wide
open you can study other issues that are
pertinent to Cooperative school
districts
we're looking at the benefits of a
Cooperative School District
the cost Savings of Cooperative school
district and that's all I would think be
part of this study
yeah
um so Rick I think one of the one of the
things that jumps out to me though on
this is and I think this is what Linda
was talking about too is it's it's very
very prescript prescriptive and detailed
when it comes to withdrawal or
dissolution
um you know uh
JK you know
um you know except yeah and then and
then you've got that sort of and
anything else that you might want to uh
uh you know come before the commission
as well but but
um being so prescriptive when it comes
to withdrawal
um I wonder if if maybe you know we
could sort of you know you know back out
a little bit and and look at the the
commission's duties shall be to um to um
I like the one that you put in identify
key elements required school districts
um required almost Cooperative School
articles of agreement I think that that
that's an important
um issue there and then you know terms
surrounding
um
not just withdrawal and dissolution but
what if another another uh pre-existing
School District wants to join
um you know something around that and
then we currently have a lawsuit pending
in Superior Court
um the Rand suit which which challenges
uh funding of Cooperative
um it's specifically around Cooperative
school districts I believe all the all
the plaintiffs um or the initial
plaintiffs were were Co-op School
District members of Co-op school
districts
um and and you know that could certainly
contribute to criticism of um of you
know current you know current
Cooperative school districts if if um
let's say one you know uh taxpayers in
one town are paying a significantly
higher local property Local School uh
property tax rate than than people in
other towns and so perhaps that should
be
rolled into this as a high level thing
to look at particularly in view of the
fact that we've got a pending court case
I I think that's extremely important
um and perhaps when we look at the very
first Roman numeral one where it says
they're establish a commission study
issues related to Cooperative school
districts we could add in another
sentence or two in there to give an
overall purpose of this study which is
Broad enough to conclude some of those
uh topics of which have just been
discussed this morning to show the
rationale behind why we went there or or
why we have them what's the benefit that
comes from them versus uh yeah we
understand that two of the bills which
we have before us were dealing with
reapportionment withdrawal
and the last one uh and repeal
Cooperative school districts so that the
bills which we hadn't promised were
really at that withdrawal and
disillusionment
and I think that's from what I hear by
way of all the testimony of the years
those are the big issues how do we
reapportion membership on these uh
Cooperative boards how do we get out of
it if we don't like it uh how do we get
out of it if they're trying to change
the articles of agreement where it's now
we used to be maybe uh based on your
Finance 100 admin average daily
membership now they want to throw in 50
ADM and 50 property valuation
uh all those things are causing concerns
out there when you so
like we said at the very beginning we
don't want to get down the nitty-gritty
and all this stuff but I think we got to
convey to the commission some of the
issues which have become for this
Committee in the past and here they are
yes
I just want to mention to part of the
dissolution some of it should be done to
take care of the situation like in Derry
they are Cooperative school districts of
themselves
because I was Dairy and dairy Village or
something and that all went away but
they still are a Cooperative School
District so the the dissolution part of
it needs to be done like hey if there's
nobody left it's automatic or something
to that effect because Gary doesn't know
how to get rid of it you know we we
don't know how to get rid of virus
either up in Haverhill where I uh
Cooperative District of one town with
seven at Large
uh members on the board
um
um I'm kind of drawing a blank here but
um with the with the Cooperative school
districts one of the things on on my
campaigning is that I've had several
questions about would it be more
efficient and cheaper uh for schools to
join in cooperatives or you know to have
the sau's not be all broken up into
little itty bitty saus like they are now
so I think there's there's not only you
know the louder voice obviously is for
the the breaking up of cooperatives
because somebody's mad but on the other
hand I think there are people out there
in the communities who are looking
towards
um school funding savings uh by joining
together either you know the the SAU
which isn't a Cooperative but then with
Cooperative districts as well so I I
that's why I think we should uh when we
have an overall study I think we should
look get both ways so you're you're
almost getting into the arena that
you're looking at the entire educational
structure and organization in the state
of New Hampshire
um that's what some of the other states
have grappled with they've you know
that's what Vermont did and that how do
we get away from all the duplication of
administration and these how many
districts do we have in in of the 30
co-ops there was like
174 or so small districts that are part
of the co-ops
um that's a that's uh and every one of
them has to have a you know a certain
Administration and all that there's
duplication for short uh and then how do
you develop the cost of that
Administration then that's there's a
fight on that
I think uh because we're on the western
side of of New Hampshire uh and we get a
lot of news from New Hampshire or
Vermont radio and TV and newspapers that
that that kind of sparked that
conversation since Vermont you know
really looked at the reorganization and
tried to see how they could uh entice
people to to join those small uh school
districts together so I think that's
where it's coming on my side
representative
hey Mr chairman I
um I haven't been privy to the ongoing
study and I the committee's been working
on I do understand that the free bills
that you're focusing on do uh deal with
dissolving but I I have to support uh
representative Tanner's concern when I
look at this as a first day in first
thing he gave us 10 minutes ago the
first piece the first item number one it
talks about issues related to corporate
school districts as the primary focus
doesn't say that's number one if it
doesn't have anything there as Linda has
indicator that talks about the
positiveness how to structure all those
things everything here when you get the
two three and four are valuable for the
disillusionment so I do think since the
number one piece that Doe put in there
on this commission should include the
positive ramifications of an options of
Cooperative school districts so I would
I would support representative's
concerned that this that as we go
through if it's the commission is going
to look at corporate school districts
there should be also the the a fair
presentation on the other side of the
board of how towns could do that that's
all so perhaps when we're represent
Woodcock when we make our
recommendations up or down that we don't
have to hand in the recommendations like
this in a legislative fashion we could
put down an uh an overall purpose
statement for why we're making this but
then have some bullets not in any
prioritization order but some bullets
that the that need a look at okay thank
you that might be one way of doing it uh
because we're we're not recommending
this legislation we're dealing with the
old legislation and so but we want to
make a recommendation that we didn't act
positively saying yes the bill goes
forward simply because there's too many
of these type of issues associated with
it that we're not ready to make that you
know recommendation one way the other
yet okay commission study thank you
chairman yeah further discussion on this
one
representative
I don't know that we have to put all the
positives but I certainly think we need
to put how to join a pre-existing
Co-op and how to form a new co-op as
part of the list of things that we're
Rick
I absolutely agree with that
um and I think if we're if if we're
looking to um to not recommend the
current legislative or recommend future
legislation uh uh you know form a a
commission to take a comprehensive look
to review and Rec make recommendations
for
um
for think for things including
withdrawal and dissolution joining in
formation you know you can't have the
withdrawal and dissolution yeah
discussion without adjoining in
formation
discussion too
um and the articles I think that was a
really good catch and um and I would put
funding
um in there too since it's all part of
it
and and I think though you know those
are four very broad categories that I
think would uh would provide a a decent
framework for um for a piece of
okay I got those down joining in
formation and funding uh and the in the
I I do think uh what we've discovered
this morning too is that obviously those
who have come before us
in the past
um have had issues had problems what has
been lacking in the conversation though
is where is it working
and I think that's the the last several
comments of uh committee members here
have indicated that there are places
where they are in fact working and uh
what is the best practices within those
uh co-ops that might help other co-ops
that are struggling so I think the the
expansion of the issue of the study of
co-ops is really Beyond just the
withdrawal but how in fact are how
should they be working where are they
working where are their problems and
trying to identify that that whole scope
of issues
thank you yeah we don't we have about
two-thirds that haven't really
communicated with us and so are we to
assume that's all fine are are there are
articles of agreement are they working
because they're all these articles we've
looked at what we could find and we've
looked at a good 15 or 18 of them
um in past years we found that all
different and some are very
comprehensive some are like you know one
or two pages and a lot of us you know
make your mind up as you go on
so where are the best practices
occurring and which are the articles of
agreement that really work we haven't
gotten all those we don't know and we
don't even know those that are working
well uh so this all makes sense I think
we need to you know find all this
information out before we throw it all
out with the bath water the whole works
and Rick to to your point on the on the
Articles uh I think it ties in with
Mel's point on what our best practices
in terms of operations because those two
things really you know I I think can can
can help
you know advise how to move forward with
with what what would be the things to
have in articles because as as your
friend um Bill ardinger said in the
Concord Monitor yesterday he was on the
um the charter commission for Concord
and uh the Concords Charter it's really
it's something that's that comes into
play during the breakup
it's not relied on for normal you know
day-to-day operations and um and so you
know so having having good articles that
are both both strong in terms of in
terms of um in terms of when when
there's conflict
um would also I think good articles
would be would be you know would it
would be good to have strong articles in
terms of you know solid operations as
well yeah and you kind of identify those
key elements that are within those
articles and they may all apply to every
District but in different ways because
your different sizes rural urban uh
demographic size of enrolled population
um
don't reverse non-donor
uh all that
represented cordelli thank you um with
the Articles
um I think one of the issues is
um requiring a periodic review of the
articles
um put that in into statute but there's
a fundamental problem also with the
Articles because
um if they are again voted on by the
entire Cooperative District again it's
the larger towns that are going to
dominate and if the smaller towns who
have issues
um cannot make an impact in terms of the
Articles and changes to the Articles you
know we're back to the same situation we
are currently in right right but that's
up to the commission too that that's
more yes but that's a point that the
commission would need to look at
it's all about local control and that's
the different cult one to get around
some of the articles read that if you
change these articles during the time
that we've reapproved and maybe every
five years ten years some have never
done that if you change the Articles
without our approval we have a free
ticket to get out of the the co-op there
is one District like that that is about
ready to pull that card
so uh I think this whole study is very
important
um and we ought to move on it and
hopefully if we can change you know and
summarize some of these instead of
putting the laundry list perhaps
um
um if representative Tanner do you have
your hand up quickly yeah yeah I just uh
just to go back to the the commission uh
as a whole the the uh membership of it
um and I know because you said there is
a law now that you have to have
legislative uh more legislative uh
people on the commission but as I go
down through the commission there's only
one outside group those uh state school
board or not the state school board but
the School Board Association the rest of
the ones other than legislative are all
appointed either by the doe or the
governor
um and uh I I think we need more
um diversity on that uh commission so I
don't know how much that's going to be
part of the recognition or uh
recommendation or even the final bill
but I would definitely look at the
representatives on there I think the
there's a lot more people that should be
on there than than uh that are outside
of the DOE outside of the appointment of
the governor see on on this that was the
next point I was going to get at as far
as conversation if you look at the
makeup of what is on this paper that we
received right now
you're going to see three
superintendents the uh and you're going
to see two school board members there's
five right there
and if you're only allowed to have
seven if you have a commission of 15
seven of which are going to be
non-elected officials five of them
already been reserved for the
superintendents and for
um
School Board people uh but there's
others that we've we've heard from just
like Jim who testified from the attorney
perspective you have a what about a a
finance director a business manager of
of a co-op and and and informing folks
on on the nature of uh how business is
handled financially what about the
department Revenue Administration uh
should they be involved there should be
some Doe
so the at the makeup this is where
you're going to have technical support
we're not going to be able to get them
on what about the the parent who is
upset well I don't you know if it it has
to do with the Cooperative before you
put them on there it's just you know I'm
upset because I'm not getting special
education services I don't think that's
going to be relative to this study
um however the broader picture is that
you know how's that affected the
academic achievement of my student uh
that may be a an issue which you know we
want to know about too sure sure and I
think all of those things Rick
um you know and I think this is this is
a strong point about about having a
commission maybe even a multi-year
commission to to do this so that it can
have have substantial public comment
um where where people can share those
those concerns and have ample time to uh
to seek out testimony from
um you know from the the commissioner of
the dra and from from others that other
stakeholder groups that that are
involved in um in in Co-op districts
so would it be wise for us just you know
when we're looking at this we should
also be writing in the technical support
shell include
you know and are we're not going to be
writing the Bill but in yeah
I don't want to get prescriptive but in
order we if you look at the commission
um and the membership yeah Jim Grenier
so he's from the house it kenweiler from
the house
uh Vincent migliari Department of
Education
uh Liz Brown School are were you on the
school board that your school board at
that time but you weren't doe yeah
uh uh Kathleen uh uh Eggbert
superintendent appointed by the governor
uh Carl Ladd from the school
administrators Association
Mary Heath uh elected official
John Reagan elected official uh Stephen
Hamilton dra
um Peter Bilo School Board member
appointed by the Governor Mark halora
h-a-l-l-o-r-a-n
superintendent appointed by the governor
Barrett Christina School Board
Association Donna green public member
with experience withdrawing from a
Cooperative School District I think that
was Croydon wasn't it down that Donna
green yeah Timberlane okay
that that was the makeup of it and we
heard from Jim O'Shaughnessy a New
Hampshire Council of school attorneys
that he felt there needed to be more
financial knowledge on that board
dealing with some of these issues he
discussed at the last meeting
and he was going to get back to us I
tried calling him several times it's
hard to get through him
represent bone yeah thank you uh yeah
one of the problems is the size of
commission is I think 15 is pushing it
um you need to also get a quorum uh the
thing is like a lot of bills and and the
following will be invited uh they don't
have to be permanent members of the
commission they can be invited people
like from the dra or what not to discuss
specific items but over 15 you're
getting to be
ah it's gonna be hard getting I mean
I've seen commissions come up with like
33 members and that's ugly ridiculous 15
is I think the top limit we should have
from for at least getting a quorum and
getting I mean with more than 15 you
might not even be able to agree on
anything so I think 15 is fine Liz do
just want a point of clarification so on
my list the recommendation was that
certain folks were appointed by the
State Board of Ed not by Department of
Ed those are different entities and I
think one of the things that the
commissioner and I noted as we were
going through this is the state board is
given
um several obligations with respect to
Cooperative districts and the state
board has really been sort of outside of
the realm of any prior study commission
and they at least need to be part of the
conversation
um so maybe either by representative of
the state board on that commission
um or have some participation so just
want to make that clarification that
those folks are not going to be
appointed by the agency but were
actually the suggestion was they'd be
appointed by the State Board of
Education
and then the importance of including
a discussion of the obligations of that
state board because for example they
have an obligation to review the
withdrawal plans if they're submitted
and as you know there's an issue right
now before the State Board
regarding you know a vote to withdraw
that
um
didn't go through successfully so they
the State Board certainly has
obligations under the current statute so
part of probably needs to be part of the
conversation but also part of the issues
that are discussed to make sure that the
duties and obligations that they are
given are clearly defined and things
that they can you know perform because
if it's vague and unclear or not clear
Direction it's uh moves things open
thank you
yes uh representative Allison thank you
Mr chairman just uh I'll comment on the
composition of the of the uh of the
commission uh it seems when people have
said this but I'm just supporting it
seems very much skewed toward the
Executive Branch if you include the
Department of Education and the governor
they're appointing nine people at this
commission as far as I read it we get
basically the legislative branch gets
four members uh and in terms of sort of
the division in terms of responsibility
and I'm aware of some of that between
the state board and the actual
Department of Education given the
meeting current meaning of the minds
between the commissioner of education
and the chair of the State Board of
Education I'm not sure there's a whole
uh be a whole lot of difference in terms
of the recommendations that came forward
so I think it is this membership if it's
capped at 15 which it is has to be much
more balanced than what's showing up on
this sheet here and by balanced uh you
mean that for example if it's a
15-member commission or some odd number
less than that the majority is going to
be elected representatives senators
is it possible that elected
representative could also come on with a
lot of understanding about school boards
having been a school board member or
withdrawal process could have been
involved with that or could have been
involved with a a co-op that works just
you know wonderfully
so I I think that when I look at that
list initially how we had it in the
years past
the membership was kind of siled
um from this organization from this
organization I'd rather see people
appointed to a commission and find out
what do they bring to it as an
individual not just because they're
elected or Not Elected but what do they
bring that's going to and what do we
need on there to have a good
understanding of discussion
if you don't or the knowledge of who to
contact I I think that's the important
part so we got what kind of resources
we'd want in all these different people
all right I just I and I should have
said I I certainly agree with with your
intention the intention of people here
of including as many knowledgeable
people in this process as possible uh in
terms of technical assistance and
committees and so on uh what I'm raising
is what is the composition going to be
of the group that makes the final
decision when the votes are taken really
doesn't make any difference with the
technical assistance committee said it's
the people who are on this commission
who will make a final determination
ultimately I assume on legislation or
recommendation for legislation so I that
that's my I I just want to be clear that
I certainly support the idea of lots of
people being involved in the process
foreign
thank you I think we're now discussing
what the future bill is going to be not
um I think we need to stay with this
thing on the interim study which we
pretty much all agreed to that that will
be it we have plenty of time to discuss
what the bill is going to be when we get
the bill so I think we're going further
than we should be right now
representative Tanner
um I would uh respectfully disagree
about individuals versus
um organizations I think uh that when
you have like a Carl Ladd from the
Superintendent's Association that that
person then represents uh the general
feeling of superintendents in the state
if you have just one superintendent from
one particular area they they're just
representing their particular area which
then can can get skewed so when you do a
Statewide commission I think you need to
look at a mix of maybe an individual but
also have representative from the
organization just like you're having the
school boards association with Barrett
Christina
foreign
I think representative Bowman's correct
this would be a decision that needs to
be made but I think the makeup of these
commissions is extremely important uh
and I'm sure that the governor in past
when he's appointed people has tried to
look at that in terms of people that are
bringing some knowledge certainly did
that when he appointed Bill ardinger to
the commission that you had
um so uh
is there anything else on this that we
okay let's look at the individual three
bills right now
okay in the first bill which is
uh 1366 relative Cooperative School
Board reapportionment
how is what's the feeling up or down on
that
is anybody uh wanting this to move
forward we got to make a recognition
here's the sort of getting back to what
we started to talk about at the top of
this if um if we're not recommending
either of the any of these bills in
their in their specifics but instead are
recommending that the legislature
um assemble a uh a commission to do a
comprehensive review
um then that I think having having our
having a three sentence uh report that
um that you can draft on the fly right
now could give us a you know a sense of
of how we want to vote on these uh these
bills because I I you know I think I
think maybe this could go to I mean I'll
just put out a straw man
um that that that the committee does not
recommend this this bill
in specific but does recommend and this
would be the common for all three does
recommend a comprehensive commission to
to study uh issues to study matters
um of Cooperative school districts with
respect to to at least the following
areas withdrawal dissolution joining in
formation
um articles of agreement funding and
best practices and operation and and
just sort of leave it at that that's
exactly right not get into membership we
need to take action in each bill though
and we're gonna have to make that same
motion for each bill right right but if
if if that was it if if
um if we knew what those what that one
sentence or what that one you know yeah
um okay so then what we need to do right
now then just to make this easy so we
don't string this thing on too much
longer we'll we'll make that motion and
make it appropriate to each of the three
bills
um when we have that motion if we all
agree in that process that's what I'd
like to hear right now because if I
don't see that now we haven't made a
decision to pass on to the executive
session and that's what we want you know
when we exec the three bills so is
everybody favorable behind what was just
mentioned represent cordelli yes
um since this is uh
subcommittee but a committee of the
whole and on the 24th we have a
committee of the whole do we have to
have a vote
um today there are a number of members
missing today
um wouldn't it be uh better just to
delay any vote until we have a true
executive session uh with the committee
of the whole
no we we are in a subcommittee and as I
mentioned yesterday
that even though the folks unless we
haven't finished studying the bill
but I think at this point with this bill
and three bills I think where there's
nothing else to be gotten and so we we
should make a recommendation at this
point in time as a sub committee uh
we're gonna have to do that you know we
could do that on the 24th at the same
time
but my feeling is that we're all pretty
much going to be on the same page here
anyways right now so Rick I'd be happy
Okay so we've a motion made by represent
luno SEC my represent boom so that that
we uh that and this applies to all three
bills I don't have the numbers in front
of me yeah um
um that uh that that that that while the
committee does not recommend this bill
for further legislation it does
recommend the legislature assemble a
commission to study matters
that's your first sentence second
sentence yeah these matters shall
include
withdrawal and dissolution joining
information
articles of agreement
funding and operating best practices and
I would put other matters as pertain to
Cooperative school districts yeah yeah
that's that would be the last point of
that yeah okay okay
okay
all in favor
we didn't have any discussion on that
we're done with that now okay and that's
times three that's that's three times
three so we're done that those three
bills are taken care of we're going to
take a five or five minute break here
before we get into the next bill
I'm gonna I'm just gonna copy it right
now
did you get a copy of what he just said
but yeah no
and I thought you were writing oh that
okay so you've you've got it though
okay we're going to go ahead and start
on 1680.
subcommittee interim study work on on
this uh bill has
uh as a result of commission studies in
the past task force studies in the past
and and here we go in terms we we are
now trying to come up with some
resolution on 1680 here
uh in terms of uh the recommendation
from this committee I passed out several
sheets here
which I asked this sheet right here the
one which has all those these districts
on it uh yesterday I I met with uh
Jennifer for uh to ask for information
one of the concerns it's just one that's
I I've thought of a lot lately is that
we have some districts that are wealthy
districts and we know that we saw from
the commission report too where there
were outliers on just about everything
we did or in Liars whatever you want to
call them and and
um where for example there's a high
number of dollars that are driven
towards and make up the uh cost per
pupil and equalize valuation per pupil
is also High however their achievement
scores are not where you think they
should be
uh given the nature of that community
and there's a lot of reasons for that I
understand a lot of variables some are
our funding some are non-funding
variables
and so what I'd like to do is just take
a moment if we can here because before
we do any kind of recommending or moving
forward
I'd like to have today everybody here at
the table that's got
um uh either a a made-up position you
know or you've already resolved where
you are on this or you haven't uh to put
your cards on the table and please let's
have an honest discussion right now so
we can
try to address some of the critical
issues that the 1680 was bringing
forward and there are some issues in
1680 that are very pertinent and that
proposed to where we need to go or where
we want to go in terms of learning in
this state
um
so I'd like to look first at this uh
small little sheet which was put
together it comes from I platform I exp
the I explore from doe uh Jen do you
have a moment that you could come on up
please
Jen in this uh you were able to put this
together uh for me just the other day
um dealing with these various districts
and the districts we know
um someone like if you're a co-op and
there's towns or districts within the
co-op
the towns are listed in several
different pla they're listed as a
separate District because they might
only be a K3 a K4 k6 but they're also
listed under the co-op as well uh so but
then going across equalize valuation per
pupil you can see what uh that is in
terms of the formula that we were giving
some fiscal capacity disparity Aid
that's what I like to call it we were
looking at
a figure to start a starting point to
move downwards and as we went downwards
towards the lower level of Equis
property valuation the amount that they
receive per pupil increased
um average cost per pupil Proficiency in
math Proficiency in English language
arts uh whether it's economically
disvantaged students based on free and
reduced the percentage
and the enrollment numbers and then the
medium household income is also listed
there and these are all components that
come into our thinking on how to direct
monies in any formula
um to where there is need for that money
and and and also as an attempt to see if
the money which is being received is
being used efficiently uh towards the
the area of the we measure
that outcome which we're looking for in
in the commission study there were I
believe three outcomes which were
measuring from the Statewide assessment
attendance and graduation numbers
am I correct on that yeah and so it was
those three in in statute we have a
number of indicators which we measure
that from everything from the ASVAB to
you know uh the going on the
post-secondary education there's a
number of them uh disciplined in the
schools Etc so Jen could you walk us
through this a little bit try and
explain what the different shades of
black and gray are here
sure
um so what what I did was pull
um all of the data points from the I
platform on the department of
education's website except for the
median household income that comes from
from the U.S Census Bureau
um the I platform
produces information by district and
there are 164 districts that are listed
here
this is all 2019 data
um and like representative Ladd had
mentioned
where there is a Cooperative School
District
um from cordelli mentioned that Exeter
is a good example where Exeter
Cooperative is I think a six through 12
Cooperative than each of the member
towns are listed separately
um
with their K to six or k to five
um districts but all the data is
District level data so the proficiency
is is by the specific District
um
in terms of the shading what I did is
once I compiled the data I just used um
the quartile function in Excel to break
down
um the the
quartile so you can see relative
from District to District
um which conditions are perhaps more
favorable
um the flaw or or what I I think you
should keep in mind when comparing the
districts is it doesn't account for
district population
so the quartile data isn't going to
align perfectly with Statewide average
data because you're comparing in some
cases an 80 student district with a 13
000 student District so some of that
it's it's not it Compares things
differently than if you are looking
um at all the student performance in the
state so if you look at page six of the
packet it shows how those quartiles are
broken down for each category
um
and I also noted the Statewide averages
for each category
and then the last page gives you
information again from I platform that
defines each of the indicators that are
um obviously on the printout you can't
see the color coding so I am going to
send you around electronically the um
spreadsheet so that you can
have that visual
impact better than what you can see here
and it will also allow you to sort by
okay are there reps and boom
thank you
I I did similar thing many years ago on
education funding and one of the same
reasons I will not vote for any funding
that includes median household income
and a good example of that is for
example town of Litchfield
both parents work as compared to
Manchester which has a lot of single
parent houses and if you look at theirs
compounded to median male income a
median female income it's the median
household is nearly the same if you look
at it for Litchfield for example the
median you add the two together and you
get the median so it's not a fair
comparison to use median household
income anyway so I just wanted to bring
that up and it and for example Hudson
which is nearly identical Litchfield it
shows in nearly half
and and that's because there are
probably a lot of single family
single uh
provided for single provider household
in Hudson that's compared to Litchfield
so it's not a fair comparison I mean
both parents like in Midfield and a lot
of the other towns you see the high
numbers is the only reason it's high is
because both parents have to work in
order to live where they're living so I
mean that's why I will never vote for
anything that has median household
income because I went through this years
ago when we were doing the same type of
thing and
and why isn't Dairy on the list
this is completely everything that came
out from
um the I platform data I didn't add or
take away any of the districts they're
missing you
yeah
magnetic ended up
so Rick yes just a question on on
Ralph's um comment there and and I I
agree with what he said and nothing in
actually nothing in 1680 uh relies on
median household income as part of the
funny formula but our current and what's
being proposed well it uses free and
reduced price lunch
right
which is different than median household
income it's a it's a poverty indicator
for the or socioeconomic status
indicator for um uh for students and uh
and it's it's very clear from the um I'm
also looking at the same database that
uh that Jen used and I mean we had a
really nice presentation of it from from
uh the department what a couple weeks
ago and just looking at the economically
disadvantaged students percentage versus
Proficiency in math
um and uh and there's a it's a very
strong correlation uh there with um with
with students from economically
disadvantaged um uh backgrounds
performing uh significantly worse on the
um on our Statewide assessments than uh
than students in more affluent
um uh households
so if if we look at a town like a
moultonborough
and I'm not picking on it but I'm
picking on it only because I'm looking
at the recoice valuation is seven
million dollars per pupil
um
and their average cost per pupil is 25
687 dollars
and you look at the performance in
mathematics
what was the state average in
mathematics can you Recology 49 49
they're below the average
so they're 42 percent
um
if in fact
uh where
I I'm concerned that
how do we direct dollars
to assist those communities which have
low performance in a certain subject
area or area of learning
yet they have the ability within their
community
um
so I guess that's a that's a question
Dave yeah
and and Rick I mean I think that's
that's something that we spent a lot of
time in in the year 2000 on Zoom uh
talking of talking about and um and and
I think we we you know we focused a lot
of discussion around the um uh the
Supreme Court decision that came out of
the Londonderry lawsuit and um and where
where um where I think it I'm not
recalling the the the specific language
I know it's in the commission report but
um
but but I think um you know some critics
have used the Londonderry decision as to
support a first and last dollar approach
to funding an adequate education uh but
I don't believe the Londonderry decision
I'm not a lawyer
um uh necessarily goes goes to that
effect but uh but very important I think
for um for the state to look at its
obligation to providing the last dollars
uh uh in making sure that every district
has access to the resources they need
and I think that would apply to to a lot
of the um the underperforming
um
districts where students are are
performing below the state
um uh the state average and making sure
that that they have um you know the
dollars to uh to fund an adequate
education
and and I think that's the that's that's
the rub and I think you and I yeah uh
you know battled over this but your data
here is is
is is I mean what you're what you're
talking about is directing State funds
where they're needed
as opposed to on a universal uniform
basis
yeah yes the premise
on
the the
formula which Bill and your Dave and Mel
put together their bill you put it
together probably our dick excuse me
um uh was built upon that Doe 25 form
right wasn't it it was about
20 000 or so at what was no it was B
so it's 17 plus
okay well it was it was it was based on
it was not based on the average cost for
a student
um uh it was it was it was based on all
of them sorry I didn't have my speaker
on
um the um the the commission study
analyzed all of the doe 25
FY 19.
because we did the study in in 20.
and Dick correct me I mean you know I'm
hoping if I'm getting this right here uh
and and it looked at
how districts spent their budgets and
and
normalized that with with what the
outcomes were in those districts was
there was there an assumption
that due to the fact that New Hampshire
consistently is seen in comparison to
the rest of states in America
that we have very good achievement
and so is there an assumption made then
the the this average whatever it is
amount for the pupil cost should be
enough to maintain that level of
achievement if we're all yeah so so I
think that works when when looking at
the state as a whole but when you start
looking at individual school districts
the um the the average student in
Manchester does not
um does not necessarily isn't identical
to the average student in um in New
Hampshire and and so the the the student
characteristics in Manchester are very
different than the average student
characteristics across the state so what
what the what the commission study found
is that in some districts
the um the the average cost per student
in order to achieve a Statewide outcome
this very strong Statewide average
outcome is going to cost more than uh
than in other districts and um and so
that you know I think you know what the
the commission's findings really move us
away from a uniform cost and and fund
model to a a cost model that um that is
specific by District because every
district is well not every District's
totally different but um but uh you know
the the um
the the student the the
challenges that that Manchester has just
aren't the same as the challenges that
uh that Hopkinton has or that Hanover
has and it's not the same as the
challenges that Berlin so let's take a
look at Tamworth on your on your sheet
yeah
um Tamworth has a free and reduced
population
of 54 percent
so it's a poverty-stricken area
according to that
their equalized property valuation
though is 1.3 million which is you know
on the high side compared to many
and yet their proficiency area in
mathematics is 26 percent and they're
spending 28 000 per student right yeah
and they've got 185 kids out of the 155
kids 160 000 that uh that we've got
Statewide so how does this formula we're
talking about address this particular
need of that town well I could uh I
could I could take a look at the the
company remember we developed through
our our um our Consultants with air
developed a district calculator and we
could specifically look at at Tamworth
um and see what uh see what it would
recommend for a um for funding uh level
I
don't forget cameras is only in
elementary school
see I I yes yes it is it's not our whole
system yeah but that's that's good to
know and and the um the the Air Research
you know did take a look at at what what
um you know age groups are being served
and and not all got factored and that's
why going through the ms-25
in detail is really essential when
determining the uh a funding model and
uh not just looking at the yeah
thank you
so can you then when you're looking at
that calculator for that particular
community
compared to what they receive now by the
current Formula what they what would
they be receiving in the Foundation
program that you're proposing
so
let me get Tim work so we're talking
about Tamworth let me pull up the
calculator I don't have it yeah
so go Rick this is going to take me a
minute okay so when you get that yeah
yes represent Cornell Thank you um I are
there ways to look at other things like
I think in our discussion the other day
we talked about how students in
Manchester at certain elementary schools
enter school not ready to learn at all
not even knowing their colors but we're
maybe in Lebanon because they've had
parents sitting home with them reading
with them or they've gone to preschool
for three years old four years old and
they're entering school probably reading
so is there a way to know if Tamworth
are they entering School first grade
maybe not ready to learn because they
and so by third grade they've not caught
up and their test scores will be lower
because they're not entering with that
advantage that other districts might
have entered with see Patricia represent
Cornell that's okay
um
it's you're sort of going down the path
and I'm going down that there are a
Associated issues
which
uh May uh control
to some degree the kids are coming to
school education in the family
aspiration of the family aspiration of
the community economics within the
demand for jobs within the community
leadership in the building which I think
is absolutely in line number one that
um
leaderships it sets tone and and would
staff uh on on how learning progresses
and some of those issues you know you
may say yeah it's Associated to some
degree with money however we have
schools which are uh performing very
well in some of these communities where
the per pupil uh equals per valuation
per pupil is low and the uh ability of
the Town support through property taxes
is also low but they're achieving and
it's I I come down to the fact that all
the time how do we how do we measure the
effectiveness of leadership is that part
of why we're seeing some schools down
and some schools up but if we
if money toward the communities where
the kids are entering school at a
disadvantage could those communities not
use that money to provide a preschool
program for those kids or to Target
programs to kindergarten first grade
second grade to catch them up you know
have smaller classrooms have have more
reading and math
Advantage classes I think we've been
doing that in many schools that through
the title one program funds and all we
we you'll see some schools saying well
we're going to keep the pupil teacher
ratio low in the grade schools but
expanded as we get up in the grades
hoping that we can do some of the things
you're talking about prior to getting to
grade three
uh so that that's part of the equation I
also handed out another sheet to you
this one right here which just came in a
uh educational Journal just this week
and it shows that similar access to
effective teachers for low and high
income students is the same
so it's um
you have some teachers that are
effective and some that are not
effective these exist in the say at the
same level in
wealthy
towns where you have a wealthy
population and those where you have a
represent like us
yeah I had two comments on the overall
thing one is the fact that we're heading
for aiming for the average
and we may be top in or one of the top
in the country but that's not saying
much we're like 33rd in the developed
world
and I don't think the proficiencies what
was it 42 and a half or something like
that is something we should be aiming at
I think we should be aiming above that I
think we should be aiming at proficiency
as opposed to average proficiency and
the other thing is
given that both from things we see here
and from that graph we saw
there isn't super good correlation
between money spent and outcome and
we've we've seen that looking on it but
we've saw that there
and so one of the things I really like
about this
program is the whole section on for
failing schools as far as I'm concerned
42 and a half is a failing school and 65
is a failing school we're talking about
proficiency we're not talking about
Excellency we're just talking about
Precision proficiency
and so I think that should be applied
before we start divvying up money or
changing money I think we need a couple
years of apply that whole section where
they have to come up with a program for
how they're going to improve their
outcomes they're going to have you know
all that whole section that's a great
section I say let's put that in place
give it a chance to
you know
have a fact and then look at it and see
where we're at before we start giving
money when money doesn't seem to have
any real correlation to outcome so so
um couple things on on that point and
and um and I I agree I think the
accountability section in in 1680 is is
is very strong uh but at the same time
um we need to we need to have a Level
Playing Field to make sure that um well
there's a couple things that that that
districts have access to the resources
they need in order to have effective um
you know in you know instruction and
programming in their districts uh and uh
and it's it's really clear from from you
know the work that the commission did
and the report that that Jen has has Jen
and Rick have provided that that
districts a lot many many districts just
don't have access to the uh to even the
the resources for um for even a even a
basic um budget but the you know another
important objective behind the
commission's work and I agree I would I
would love to have all of you know New
Hampshire students are the average
student performance in New Hampshire
much higher than it is right now I mean
being top five in the US yeah I mean
that's better than being bottom five in
the US but you're right compared to the
rest of the world
um we could be doing a lot better than
that but but one of the commission's
objectives here was really closing the
opportunity Gap so it wasn't it wasn't
to increase the average student
performance in New Hampshire but to
increase the average student in
performance where where where where in
in many districts it's so far from the
from the from the average in New
Hampshire that that these kids just
can't get a fair shake and um and you
know unfortunately you know Patty you're
always at the end of this with
Manchester
um you know Manchester and Newport
um student performance is um is at the
bottom of the state and both both are
challenged economically both have um
Manchester has significant
um
uh you know pop student populations that
come from low econ socioeconomic
backgrounds and and how many languages
are spoken 60 something in the
Manchester School District
um you know Newport doesn't have those
same challenges but they have other
challenges and the um you know the
objective was really to close those
opportunity gaps and and I'm hoping that
that the legislature will um will will
see an opportunity here and not say well
you know average in New Hampshire isn't
high enough and until we see it you know
double or be better than pick another
country that we do nothing
um because I think that's where that's
where too many kids are just being left
out of our economy right now
and um and
you know we could we could be doing a
lot better with the money that we're
that the state is currently spending
that's another big point of 1680. that
that um that it's not it's not saying
hey we need to put in
um uh some you know additional huge
tranche of uh of State dollars it's not
saying that and um and I think it
recognizes some very practical things
too that while while certainly the
Manchester school district is the most
underfunded in absolute dollars because
it's also the largest that that the
Manchester School District wouldn't be
able to absorb
um uh you know all in one year that
complete tranche of money so it would be
phased in over a decade and um and and
similarly the um any sort of tax rate
impacts that that districts might see
would be would be uh would have
transition grants that would be phased
out over five years and uh and so
reducing the um you know the uh uh you
know the the the you know taking the
shock out of the system and uh and I do
have the uh the information for Tamworth
okay
also Rick
yes represent Ford
I'm a big concerned only thank you
I'm a bit concerned that this is seen
only in the brown from the lens of the
financial part of it
I'm familiar with students in Manchester
specifically I don't have their names
but I know who they are and they come
from non-english speaking families and
they are knocking the socks off their
competitive English-speaking people in
various programs
and it's not because they are
disadvantaged in some ways they have
they take that and run with it they're
in a program now for developing their
own businesses
in high school
and this is coming from another source
outside the school system
so I don't accept this data as being
valid because it doesn't speak to the
aspirations or the education of the
parents
and I think you'll find more answers to
this problem there than you will find
several of you may remember when I was
showing a book around about children and
and work in the workforce with Lewis
Hines the photographs and pointed out
members of my own family
Barefoot picking cotton in north Texas
cotton fields
what I didn't say in that though was
every single person in that photograph
had all of their children go to college
and these were cotton Pickers barefoot
with no money
I think they're missing a big point of
the point here when you say it's only
about the finances are in the community
there are whole cultural things at work
here and I think they in addition to
this chart here we have to ought to know
what are the educational backgrounds of
the parents
what do we get plus or minus from that
so what what data are you taking
people my wife is working no no no
that's not what I'm saying or is it the
the proficiency
just the the economically disadvantaged
students and you're assuming that
performance is not necessarily going to
be good unless their economics are
improved
so so it's not simply a matter of
Economics is my point
right but the the the doe data that has
been collected and was presented to us
two weeks ago and this is on the the I
explore
um function that Nate and his colleague
that's it too yeah this is the data that
Jen Jen used and it's got a correlation
of minus 0.68 which is pretty strong
correlation between
economic disadvantage students and lower
Proficiency in math I think we I
understand there is a relationship
between being economically disadvantaged
and performance there we've gotten that
data we've had it over a number of years
um but I mean I'm hearing I'm hearing
from Oliver that that he doesn't believe
that dude my my concern is that there
are situations which don't necessarily
follow but what we you know see for the
whole and I'm concerned that in any kind
of a formula which we develop
there should be
accountability for sure that we just
handed this sheet and I'm going to look
at where representative Woodcock comes
from here Conway
and look at the equalized property
evaluation
look at the per pupil expenditure per
child cost and look at their achievement
scores
they're not good
and and
how but see they have a valuation of one
point
or 1.5 million dollars per pupil
and they're spending 18
000 per pupil
um they have a 38
so
you know it is
but with that type of Revenue available
to them shouldn't they have this score
higher if we're going to pour more money
into sending to other districts in hopes
it's going to improve those districts
but we see in fact unless money is
specifically targeted which we cannot do
Under the current constitution
interpretations
that's what I understand I'm not a
lawyer but we cannot Target a
differentiated Aid and perform and and
base adequacy money that is basically
going to the town and a school district
and they use it
do they use it for these students I
don't know
so is there are there other issues here
that come into play I'm all for many
components within the foundation for me
believe me I I advocate for a weighted
uh amounts of money for various
categories which are unfunded by the
federal government and we're not
receiving that from the state either and
that's costing us a significant problem
in our schools
so how do we address my concerns here
Dave yeah yeah so so so I think first of
all it starts with defining and costing
inadequate education and and currently
we Define an adequate education as a
classroom with with with 30
um students a teacher 1 500th of a
principal you know a principal for every
500 students one librarian for 500
students it's a bag of stuff that that
at the end of the day costs about four
thousand dollars
and and we've we've heard I think from
from from our many hearings over the
last several years that uh that there's
no school district that no Public School
in the state that um that would be able
to um to put on anything close to to
what they consider to be an adequate
education for for four thousand dollars
okay and then with that conversation
right there
so if if the base adequacy right now is
four thousand dollars
and and we're basing that on a formula
which is 25 to 1 for K through
three I believe and four through four
through twelve it's Thirty to one
in the task force back in 2018 I had
recommended that we drop that down to 20
and 25.
now the if we drop down K through three
and taking our K3 students that's that's
four grade levels and with 164 000 kids
divide you know you can find how many
kids that is multiply it by the an
additional sum of money which would be
going out to based upon that formula is
that not a way to address and and fix
our funding absolutely and and in fact
that's what 1680 does is it um it
recommends a base amount of enough five
thousand yeah it's like five to six
thousand dollars so it's a little bit
higher than we currently does have and
then it has
um a differentiated Aid
um weighted value it's weighted weighted
dogs but it's the same same basic thing
as our differentiated you know the
additional dollars for special education
English language Learners free and
reduced lunch and um and uh 1680 does
not do third grade reading but it does a
school size
um
aspect of it and we can argue over all
of these things but but what the base
plus these differentiated factors do is
get you closer to what a school
district's budget would look like to
educate all of its students so for for
places like Hopkinton hey I represent
Hopkinton people at Hopkinton but
hopkinton's uh you know for for for
hopkinton's average student to perform
at a Statewide average Hopkinton doesn't
have to be spending what it's what its
current budget is so from places like
Hopkinton and Hanover it ends up being
with a lower predicted budget for those
school districts for places like
Manchester it ends up being
significantly higher predicted so
predictive budget Dave this seems to be
a discussion between you and I yeah um
so Hanover we know is well-educated
community and they're they're you look
on the chart here and their achievement
score is going to be wonderful yep
um and they're spending and they've got
strong budget yeah and so
and yet and you look at Hopkinton or you
look at Gabriel you're going to see not
the type of results that you see in
Hanover no Hopkinton you get those rooms
Claremont decision right now in
Londonderry and all that
we have to allocate to these students
the same amount of money regardless of
poverty or wealth so so how's this
formula that you have get around that
decision of the courts okay
um so we don't believe it's getting
around the decision of Courts because we
don't believe that that I don't believe
I shouldn't say we don't believe I I
don't believe and and and I and
particularly with with advice and
discussion from from two lawyers who who
have who we've all know and and you and
I have have worked with Dickens bill
ardinger
um you know have been through every step
in this uh don't believe that that's
what the court
um uh meant by that and uh the court had
never seen
um a um uh a formula uh like what a like
what we're proposing in 1680 which is
directing the precious State resources
to where they're needed currently
and over gets the same amount per
student from the state as as Pittsfield
does as Berlin does as her people per
pupil as rye and Newcastle do and and
and and and and and
all of those towns have significantly
different
um
access to financial resources and uh but
they get the same amount of funding from
the state of New Hampshire all 1680 is
doing I mean among the in addition to
the accountability section and and the
tax set the um the property tax relief
section and stuff like that is um is
taking the billion dollars that the
state raises
650 million from business profits tax
business owners and price tax and a
smattering of other taxes plus the 363
million it gets from the Statewide
property tax and and pushes that out to
make sure that districts can fund
reasonable budgets because if we say as
a legislature that a reasonable budget
is is
forty two hundred dollars per student or
whatever it is right now base plus
adequacy we're we're I don't know what
we're what we're saying because there's
no there's it's not rooted in in
anybody's reality it's not rooted in
Manchester's reality and it's not rooted
in Hanover it's real it's not rude in
any reality but if we recognize that
that that reasonable District budgets
um for an adequate education for a
Statewide education
um should range anywhere from and I'm
not looking at the numbers but but
they're gonna they're gonna they're
they're gonna have a range
um depending upon the the student
District characteristics anywhere from
fifteen thousand dollars per student to
twenty four thousand dollars person
something like that that that as long as
it as as these school districts can um
Can can raise the first dollars locally
and get the last dollars they need
to to make them whole on on on on a
predicted budget for that District
then then the state I think is is doing
the job the courts and the Constitution
really intended but the courts haven't
ever seen New Hampshire do anything like
that before Vic can talk about this a
lot if you're talking about the
Massachusetts model here um I'm talking
about the Massachusetts model and my
understanding from dick and from bill is
that the Massachusetts Constitution is
very similar to the New Hampshire
Constitution when it when it surrounds
when it pertains to Our obligation to
yeah we keep talking about how much uh
Town spends for
per pupil spending and I'm saying it's a
whole lot more complicated than that you
look at for instance Lisbon Regional
their equalized valuation per pupil is
only six that 634
000 whereas Manchester it's eight
hundred and five thousand you look at
their
economically disadvantaged and they're
re they're fairly close they're in the
same ballpark
um and yet the average cost per pupil
for Lisbon is 17
000 and Manchester is twelve thousand
well the big difference well so number
one
the people in the town vote for what
their spending is and number two
they're completely different sizes one
is huge one is at the top end and the
other is at the bottom end and so you
can't just look at oh twelve thousand
you got to realize that there's a lot of
savings due to size right yeah but
that's not that's you know Patty should
be here for this oh I'm sorry I didn't
realize you'd laugh but but but but the
city of Manchester has yeah has has
other extraordinary needs
um because it's so much larger than any
other city or town in the state and I
believe it also has a tax cap and I
don't think the voters in Manchester
approve the school budget I don't know
how that's it's not it's not left to the
voters in Manchester it's the council
but it's not that it's now yeah yeah but
it's not the state either it's still the
locals whether it's the people elected
by the locals who do it but it's not the
state who does it but my point is they
still have a lot more equalized
valuation per pupil than Lisbon does and
yet Lisbon spends more per pupil than
how much of that is because they vote to
spend more and how much of that is just
because there's economy of scale
it's very complicated is what I'm saying
and you can't just look at
the property values you can't just look
at the amount they're spending because
you know how much of that comes from
what we don't it's way more complicated
and so basing on these simple things you
can see right there it doesn't work
yeah and and and and and and
you know and I I'm not trying to get
down into the weeds of of of 1680 but uh
but it does recognize that there are
efficiencies for larger school districts
so in in those areas Manchester actually
does not um receive any any benefit
because of its um school size uh in in
terms of uh predicted costs
um uh however it does have such a high
number of English language Learners that
it does receive differentiated aid for
um uh for that
um and and again just looking at the at
the school and student related factors
but I think Patty could probably tell
you about a lot of other factors outside
of the Manchester School District that
affects that affects the total tax rate
that Manchester residents
um you know pay for what fire and police
safety and other I things that go beyond
Shannon Tanner
yeah I'm just um
uh looking at the sheet that was passed
out for 2019 which is was an unusual
year and it's a one-year look at one
year snapshot of the schools in the
state
um and you're bound to have outliers and
the smaller the school is the more
variation you're going to get over a
number of years so if you really wanted
to you know compare data a little bit
better I would suggest that you do a
five-year average and certainly covet
changed a lot of of uh scores and
everything else I think the other thing
is that you need to look at Apple
samples you know when you're looking at
the proficiency of kids in the United
States or New Hampshire versus uh the
United States or versus other countries
it's not Apples to Apples and and I
guess my third point is that
and it goes to what Dave's been speaking
about there's so many factors within the
community and the longer the community
has had a poorer performing school like
Newport uh more poverty uh less industry
or or professional people moving into
the area because they come they have a
job and they say okay where's the best
school district in the area Newport
doesn't get the nod and so it's become a
lot of slumlords uh that have bought up
property from out of state that just let
the property go which exacerbates the
the whole it's a spiral that goes down
so even if you when you at least start
something like this it's going to take a
while for things to to actually make any
kind of turnaround but I it certainly is
um at least from living in Sunapee
representing Newport representing some
other towns that I did in my floaterial
you know Dave's right there's a lot of
factors the preschool how many how many
parents actually send their kids to
preschool that would be one question I'd
have with Tamworth versus maybe Newport
they certainly offer preschool but how
many parents send them to preschool so
um you know we're dealing with children
and we're dealing with Learners and
Learners are hard to fit in pegs they're
not widgets like in a business so
whenever you try to make data and data
points it's difficult and there's going
to be outliers but and you try to do an
average so that you get to see it and um
you know in those schools with 42
percent math you might have a couple of
really math whizzes you know and you
might have a couple of kids that are
have rumorophoria or whatever it is but
it's like dyslexia with math I mean we
don't we don't even take that into
account like we do dyslexia and some of
the other issues that we've identified
in reading so
I would just caution everybody about
grabbing these and looking at Lisbon or
looking at Tamworth
um you know 2019 again wasn't a great
year and and uh certainly it's it's a
one-year flash of what's happening in
New Hampshire schools in response to
that uh represent Tanner
um
we're taking the information that we
should we have available to us and it's
limited from Doe
um we we can go back further and uh some
of these low math scores which we're
talking about are nothing that's been a
result of uh not necessarily resultant
of the pandemic 2019 is actually free
that's pre-pandemic so we're looking at
it but we are looking at
seeking more information that's the
purpose of the analyst over at doe to do
that so we can track one cohort as they
grow through the grades one thing about
Lisbon you're looking at Lisbon there
and that's within my area uh Lisbon if
you drive down 302 it looks like a bomb
went off in places
it's not a very very wealthy community
at all but their scores are above
Proficiency in both mathematics and in
language arts reading
and it's because they have outstanding
leadership and staff in that school I've
seen it they have a wonderful Athletic
program too in soccer I can tell you
that they've beaten Haverhill
um
so
people just won a state championship the
other night
um
in that division but at any rate
um the the school district also relies
with a very close relationship in Lisbon
with New England wire which is a a
company which does business throughout
this world and in in fiber optics and
all that and it's huge so
there are these outliers that have high
Proficiency in there or above the
proficiency level
that are weak on the equalized property
valuation as Lisbon is if you look at
that you're going to see it in well well
below a million dollars I'm sure
and and and then if you look at their
achievement scores they're just a little
shallow the 50 Mark they're well above
the 42 percent Mark 40 probably 47.49 in
that area
so how do we direct the money to these
particular districts and if you look at
their poverty level it's well up above
so they're they're one that has the
poverty they have these very unique and
difficult issues but somehow they're
showing good achievement
in terms of where we place the bar and I
understand sometimes representative bar
is too low to the ground
um for proficiency and we go in terms of
our academic standards maybe we've got
to raise that a little bit so we can
really
compete worldwide and direct more
attention to how we're teaching and
identifying what our curriculum should
be representative yeah let's step back
just a moment
um when the current when the current
system was created
years ago way before all of our thoughts
they really only had one thing to look
at
and that was to look at things
this is what David said earlier
things this is the input model the way
we're currently funding schools
Things based upon average salary of
teachers
percent of
principles how many desks you've got
there that's all they had at that point
in time
and they came up with a formula and they
have okay based up all that everybody
gets four thousand dollars period
that was okay then
they did not have the data sets that we
currently have
if you look to see what the Department
of Education has been able to do with
the form 25
Etc we've looked at some of the data
they've had there's a whole new set
of criteria that you can base how we
fund schools
and I think what 1680 is trying to do is
to say okay let's take this new data
we've got
and let's see how we might be able to
reallocate the current way we're funding
schools
and reallocate them in a way that's
going to help those areas that need more
help
so that's one point so just think about
the old system and a potentially new
system based upon data that we've that
we didn't have when the old system was
created
the second thing that we haven't talked
about here yet
and that is what the commission really
focused on too
is that how do we make sure that
students in this state
have equal access to an adequate
education
and that's being fun that's being
focused on how do we create a Workforce
within this state
that there is some comparability around
the state so if you want to have if you
want to have a business that's going to
go into Claremont for example or Newport
they can look at the students there and
say gee these kids have the same kind of
an opportunity as they do in Hanover in
Portsmouth and in in Hopkinton Etc
and so the question is is how do we as
state officials
begin to look at how do we look at all
students across the state
to make sure that they have an equal
access to a good education and let's
face it in some school districts they
have great access other school districts
they don't have access and by the way
we've got data now that can tell you
that
and back to the point that that uh was
made earlier
right now when we allocate funds to
schools there is no way to say well is
it being effective
this system for the first time
has an opportunity to say hey
school districts let's see exactly how
well you're doing
and if you're not doing well there's a
five-year plan here in this system I
think it's five years
to begin to move to see where you are at
the end of that five years if you've
gotten additional money that's never
happened before
that's why I think that what the
commission's work did it's it it
revolutionizes the way we fund schools
and it revolutionizes the way we look at
how we can help kids who may be in those
school districts that don't have the
same opportunities as other kids that
are in more wealthy school districts
so I do I just Rick I just wanted to
make those two points of how we funded
it
it's obsolete right now based upon the
data that we have and secondly how do we
begin to reallocate the current funds
not additional money coming into the
state the current amount of money that
we're spending how do we reallocate that
in a more effective way than we
currently have as a one-size-fits-up
thank you represent cordelli uh just
following up on that maybe we should
look at
um the uh CSI and TSI schools who are
the lowest performing they are getting
additional resources additional funds
what happens after five years in those
schools are they showing Improvement we
should look at that as well
representative Luna
so thanks thanks again and this has been
a good a good you know robust discussion
I think that's important but I think one
of the things that that um
maybe and Rick I think you were really
moving us to focus on this and maybe
this should really be the focus on on
this is whether or not the legislature
believes
um that that the state is obligated for
to fund the first and last dollar of um
of of uh for a public education for for
public schools or uh or whether it can
direct or Target State funds where
and so so yeah so for first and last
dollar I think that this goes to the to
what Mel was saying in terms of how
Antiquated our our school funding
approach is but it's been
um in New Hampshire has always lowballed
this cost of inadequate education I
think even the current cost somatic but
education was was create needed to make
sure it fit within whatever funds were
were coming from the state of New
Hampshire
um and um and packaged to be uh to to
comply with with a
um the the interpretation of a Supreme
Court decision saying New Hampshire's
got to pay for all of it to find an
adequate education and pay for for all
of it so while we've got school
districts that are that are spending
um well like Waterville Valley average
uh forty three thousand seven hundred
thirty two dollars per student and just
to keep us on the same page Rochester
fourteen thousand twenty one dollars per
student doesn't matter you're going to
get forty two hundred dollars per
student from the state whether you need
it or not so Waterville Valley spending
forty three thousand dollars per student
Rochester spending fourteen thousand
dollars per student both get the same
amount of funding from the state and
both have very different student now
outcomes as well from based on
um based on the the report that that Jen
provided so so I I would have a hard
time imagining out of fairness that and
out of out of student fairness for
students that that that you know I don't
want to presume what the Supreme Court's
going to do but I'm not an attorney but
you look at something like this it
doesn't say it doesn't yell out to me
that oh yeah the states just got to
provide the first and last dollar the
first of the you know the forty two
hundred dollars first and last dollar of
a lowballed cost of inadequate education
where this is what districts are
spending this is what districts are able
to to raise through local property taxes
and in Waterville Valley that's 43 732
dollars with uh 2019 math proficiency at
89 and Rochester
fourteen thousand twenty one dollars
with math proficiency at 43 percent and
and the state says yup
we're just going to buy the same stuff
pay for the same stuff for the same
amount for both of these um school
districts uh I you know a pecking
Waterville Valley is kind of a you know
yeah yeah
and we all know what that is but but you
know what it even it even makes the
point even more more valid because if
Waterville Valley through its local
property taxes can can go above and
beyond the forty two hundred dollars per
student it gets from the state and raise
another thirty thousand dollars per
student
um to uh to uh uh pay for public schools
why are we even sending them the 4 200
to begin with I mean I think it puts a
serious
question into what our priorities are as
a as a state and and um to say that
watero Valley you're going to get it and
and
you know Manchester and Rochester you're
going to get the same well within our
own statutes not even going to the
Constitution it's a shared
responsibility yeah yeah and so
um well you know this is this is a
healthy discussion and and uh there's a
lot a lot to it now what I'd also like
to do is just take a moment here because
I know we're getting on lunch but I just
like to say that there are certain
strengths to the 1680 that I have always
appreciated and the the performance
outcome we need to be measuring students
and and and making sure that the dollar
is achieving what we want it to do
uh the accountability section is strong
there's no reason why we shouldn't be
lifting that accountability section and
putting it into anything everything we
do uh but there there has to be
accountability for the dollars that the
state is Raising to support schools so
it's got to be
the other thing which I think is
important is that there are certain
areas that we have uh where those
differentiated Aid elements
um very difficult you know I know when I
was
years ago up in Anchorage where we had
48 different languages in the school
and that Community it was a smaller
about 250 000 uh people living in
Anchorage itself
and that was very very difficult to
raise the dollars necessary to hit that
specific need of language English
language Learners and special education
as well when the federal government
copped out and what they said they were
going to be doing and so we are picking
up the difference especially the locals
picking up a tremendous unfunded amount
of money that's where the weighted
formula I appreciate I don't know if I
necessarily agree of multiplying four
point
tour something like that times the five
thousand
added on but the whole principle in the
concept is good
lastly there's other areas like that
which I appreciate uh I'm not so sure of
of of uh using the doe 25 form I don't
want to go into that you've heard me
before on that
um
as is trying to set some kind of a
a funding amount to start with to ensure
that we're going to provide that
adequate education or that where we want
that bar
and the whole accountability for but no
matter what we do we're always going to
fall on that hole that 90 95 I would say
close to 100 percent of all the states
are doing
you don't fund based on program you fund
upon what's in the state too
and and uh you make it work and that's
what we've done in this state since
Ogden Blick to the current uh uh Senator
Estabrook formula to what we've done in
18 and what we're doing right now it's
always been what we have this type of
dollar we'll we'll figure out a formula
to equate to that dollar it's not about
program and that's typical throughout
this country though
it's very much so uh maybe Massachusetts
is an outlier I don't know but uh I'm
sure that there's some issues down there
still
um with some of those talents that you
were poor
um they're probably having to kick in a
little bit more
so
um that's my two cents right now I think
what we need to do is wrap in a second
we're not going to come to resolution on
this at this moment I know we're not but
I think there are some areas where we
can
meet and move forward
and I'd like to to work with rep San
luno here and trying to resolve that so
when we come together
at the next meeting which will be on the
24th we're going to have to make a
recommendation on this uh whether we
move that say if the whole bill is
wonderful the way it is it should move
forward I don't I don't think that's
going to get you know a a pass like that
but there are a lot of elements within
it and a lot of principles and Concepts
behind it which should be moving forward
into whatever we do in education funding
in the upcoming year here
um you know we're we're getting back
into a hold harmless there with that
five years to hold harmless well if
that's going to last us for five years
that's not too bad but I I will not go
anywhere with stabilization ever again
uh with any formula
and I hope we all agree on that so there
are some points of agreement that we can
come to together on
um so reps and boom did you have a
comments just a comment on because when
I studied this some years ago
um and I looked in Manchester
I'm just wondering if that 12 000 per
student
includes the millions they get from the
federal government for the foreign
students the language language Learners
because I know that was a lot of money
some years ago and I'm just wondering if
that's part of the 12 000 or is that
just state and local
well I think that's something I'm not
talking Grant programs like bilingual
education
yeah I remember looking at the uh the
different data some years ago and it was
um the amount of money that Manchester
and even Nashville but Manchester even
more for the uh number of students that
the federal government was
paying at the time for English language
Learners and and that kind of issue so
I'm wondering if that there are federal
dollars in Esser for that right
yeah is that part of the twelve thousand
yes
and and rev it has revenues as well
revenues expenditures and assets oh
yeah
representative woodcock
thank you chairman
um I just want to go back to a comment
you made a minute ago about the
historical perspective of budget
preparation
just went through back in the series of
it and I think that's I think that's the
attentive system where we want to be I
think we have to create a plan
then budget the plan which this does
versus create a budget and back into a
plan and that's the historical
perspective you take the dollar and
you're back into it I think we have to
look at the other way create what we
need to do or create the plan and then
budget that in versus just taking divide
as I just falling off because I just
agree I'm budgeting I understand a
historical perspective but I think it's
the wrong process
yeah
and and Rick I think you know and you
mentioned it before too and I think it's
important to recognize that that 1680
um you know really establishes a
framework
um and and more than anything else I
mean obviously it's got a lot of details
in there but the framework is really
important and that framework relies on
on both the shared responsibility
between State and and local
um uh between the state and the and the
the city or town and um and what uh what
it's you know recognizing that that that
um that cities and towns have uh have
different resources and that the state
can come in with with its again it's
precious dollars and deploy them where
they're where they're needed most and um
and and uh you know and I and I think
that's that that really is I think in
the in the spirit of of the partnership
that we have between locals and um and
the state
um really as opposed to a first and last
dollar you know approach that doesn't
get any school district anywhere close
to uh to an operating budget thank you
okay
are you starting at one okay
good thank you you know it was on it's
on the helmet software I sent you an
email buddy what channels are the one
you asking the code Spencer
I can't remember which one that was okay
okay
um is there any more discussion for
today
um we will deal with this on the 24th on
a different topic for those who served
with a new barber shop I just want to
say Manchester
um named uh a park in her honor in her
ward in Manchester uh recreational park
with a I think was a soccer softball
field and and children's equipment to
play on and really nice memorial to her
so it was really nice you need to put it
up
that's wonderful I can't even name the
number of people I've run into that new
barbershaw and both up at Plymouth State
whereas that was her school and and
whenever I talk to folks down this way
and I reference you know oh I knew a a
teacher a representative from there in
this old Barbershop
yeah she's dearly loved
represent mulling is your hand up or
just waving
just agreeing well thank you very much
everybody we will adjourn this one and
we'll come back and we'll have to deal